what I want to do in this video is think
about all of the different ways that we
can represent data so right over here we
have a list of and I'm just using this
as one form of data a list of students
scores on say the last test so Amy got
90 percent right bill got 95 percent
right cam got 100 percent right I forgot
I also got a hundred percent right and
Farrah got 80 percent right this is one
way to show data remember data is just
recorded information and it could be
numeric like this it could be
quantitative so you're recording actual
numbers or it could even be things you
could record data on how did they like
the test and they could've scored it
based on I really liked it I kind of
liked it I didn't like it or they might
have read it on a scale of zero to five
which would have been numbers but it's
numbers that are measuring people's
opinions as opposed to here we have
numbers that are measuring their actual
scores so there's all different types of
data and I don't want to get into all of
that
but let's just start thinking about
different ways to represent this data so
this is one way you could view this as a
table where you have the name let me and
then you have the score so you have your
name column and then you have your score
column and I could construct it as a
table so it clearly looks like a table
like that that's one way one very common
way of representing of representing data
and just like that that's actually how
most traditional databases record data
in the tables like this but you could
also do it in other ways so you could
record it as a as a oftentimes called a
bar graph or sometimes a histogram so
you could put score on the vertical axis
here and then you could have your names
over here and let's see the scores let's
see maybe male make this a fifty
actually let me just mark them off so
this is 10 20 30 knots too big 10 20 30
40 50 60 70 80 90 so that's and then 100
so that's 100
two three four five that would be 50
right over there and then you could go
person by person so Amy Amy record got a
90 on the exam so the bar will go up to
90 so that is Amy and then you have Bill
got a 95 so it's going to be between 90
and 100 so it's going to be right over
there Bill got a 95 and so it look like
this bill so that is Bill and then you
have cam who got 100 on the exam so make
sure
see I'm hand drawing it so it's not as
it's not as precise as if I were to do
it on a computer so this right over
there that is cams score effort got the
same score as cam so her score is going
to be let me do that in the color and f4
his color that's F first score right now
there she also got 100 so ephra ephra
and then finally Farah got an 80 so 60
70 80 so Farah got got an 80 so this is
Farah score right over here so this is
another way of representing the data and
here we see it in visual form but it has
the same information you can look up
someone's name and then figure out their
score ami scored a 90 billion
also scored 100 Farah scored and 80
there's even other ways you can have
some of this information in fact
sometimes you might not even know their
names and so then it would have be less
information but it might be a list of
scores the professor might say hey here
are the five scores that were that
people got on the exam and they would
list 90 95 95 100 100 100 and 80 now if
it was listed and if this was all of the
data you got this would be less
information than the data that's in this
bar graph or this histogram and or the
data that's given in this table right
over here
because here not only do we know the
scores but we know who got what score
here we only know the list of scores but
there's even other ways and I this is
this is and this is not an exhaustive
video of all of the different ways you
can represent data you could also
represent data by looking at the
frequency of scores so the frequency of
scores right over here so instead of
writing the people you could write the
scores so let's see you could say this
is 80 85 90 95 and 100 and then you
could record the frequency that people
got these scores so how many times do
have a score of an 80
well forgot it was the only person with
the score of 80 so you put one data
point there no one got an 85 one person
got a 90 so you put a data point there
one person got a 95 so you could put
that data point right over there and
then two people got 100 so this is one
and two let's see the other hundred is
in this color so I'm stood in the car
you wouldn't necessarily have to color
code it like this so this is another way
to represent and this is you know this
access you could just view this is the
number so this tells you how many 80s
there were how many 90s there are how
many 95s and how many hundreds so this
right over here has the same data as
this list of numbers it's just another
way of looking at it and once you have
your data arranged in any of these ways
we can start to ask interesting
questions we can ask ourselves things
like well what is the range of data what
is the range in the data and the range
is just the spread between the lowest
point and the highest point so the range
in this data it's going to be the
difference between the highest score and
the highest score is our 100 and the
lowest score and 80 so the range is
going to be the difference between the
max minus the min the maximum score
minus the minimum score so it's going to
be 100 minus 80 is equal to 20 so that
gives you a sense of things it kind of
gives you a sense of spread you could
also ask yourself well how many how many
people scored below
these are just interesting questions
below 100 and you can actually answer
that question well actually you could
have answered either of these questions
with any of these different ways of
looking at the data if you say how many
people scored below 100 well 1 2 3 how
many people scored below 100 1200 is up
here so it's going to be 1 2 3 how many
people scored below 100 1 2 3 how many
people scored below 100 1 2 3 and so any
way you look at it you would have gotten
3 and you could also ask yourself what
is the most frequent score so most
frequent most frequent and once again
you could answer that question with any
of these ways of representing this data
you could look at our original table and
you say look there's only 190 195 180
there's 200s so you'd say look there's
the most frequent scores 100 you'd see
that over here - you actually have 200s
there's only one of each of the other
scores here you also see the 200s and
here is probably the clearest if you're
looking at frequency sometimes this
might be called a frequency plot and
sometimes it's called oh well sometimes
the official it's often called a
frequency plot and you see here the most
frequent one is the one that has the
most dots on it which is 100 so anyway
that's just a very high-level overview
of how you can look at data and
different ways to represent data but the
one thing I really want you to get from
this is that these are all different
ways of representing the same data and
we could probably invent other ways of
doing it as well